let's bring in Rocco Mediate I'm sure
we're the only person only show the
called for him
you know to talk about the 10th
anniversary is that right Rocco
we're the only show that called right I
haven't done a lot of them but when when
your guys caught on we can't say no to
ban it dad that would be just stupid
well we had you on day after and I don't
know if you realize just what it was I
mean you had to feel proud of how you
played against Tiger but what do you
remember about that that whole week and
then that's final that extra day you had
with the playoff with Tiger yeah the
whole week it was one of those weeks you
know obviously Auckland there's I feel
like you either playing great at the US
Open or you're just there and and I was
playing great before the open I played
good at Memorial mr. Nicholas is
tournament then we had a week off and I
can and I'll still obviously still
playing good and I just love opens and
then Torre and an open condition which
none of us have ever seen is firm and
fast which in February when we played it
soft and wet and cold so I knew I was
gonna like the golf course I'm ready
because I like usj setup so I wasn't I
knew I'd like it and I knew it 74
thousand yards long like I wanted to
have it
I won't be okay because the ball is
gonna move on the ground and you know
tee shots and stuff so you didn't have
to hit at 4,000 yards you could just hit
it normal and we run out there where I
could play just fine from that's what
happened well that playoff the day of
the playoff how much did you and Tiger
talk reasonable amount you know normal I
didn't go out there trying to overdo
anything I just did what I usually do I
wasn't gonna be quiet or either to the
people around me you know the Matthews
my caddy and and just you know I talked
it all out of the USGA guys that's how I
get my my nervousness out or whatever I
have to talk oh but tiger I definitely
talked a little bit sure
absolutely and I had him laughing a few
times because I kept looking going why
do you what are you doing stop it just
stop it
you know I look at it that way I but I
was gonna ask you a question okay I
never asked anybody this question what
was the wide
think people were so intrigued by this I
mean I kind of know why because I think
it was supposed to be a destruction and
a blowout but what do you think as a guy
that watching it and no sports obviously
I think people looked at you as everyman
I think people saw themselves in you
where we knew we couldn't be tiger but
we saw you you were trying to take down
the king you're trying to take down you
know and you pushed him the man and it's
not like he you didn't lose the US Open
he wanted and there's a difference in
light and and I think that's what we we
looked at you and said oh my god he's
going toe-to-toe with Mike Tyson here
and you're lasting now you now you
extend it to another day and the fact
that it was I think you led after the
14th hole on that playoff yeah I'm 16 I
was one ahead you know boy what are you
thinking about well what I'm thinking at
the time is this is exactly where I was
where I thought I was gonna be when I
woke up leading this I thought when I
woke up and I said this to a few people
and I think some people look at me like
I have like three eyes and five legs I
knew when I woke up Monday's gonna win I
knew I was because I knew I was better
through the air and opens usually or one
through the air Peter Green and then you
put reasonably well and you you know you
have a shot at it as you'll see it this
week probably the leader in fairways
he's probably gonna win this tournament
you know cause but some the great the
greatest of all time can do things a lot
of different ways but I also thought was
this Daniel business Larry's so I'm
thinking I've obviously I watched him
for four days I played behind them on
Saturday in front of him on Sunday I
heard things honey I saw the finish on
basically I was watching him Eagle the
last 15 and 18 and excuse me for
whatever 13 18 am I'm watching all that
I'm also thinking of myself this man
being the greatest still can't possibly
do this for five straight days
it can't happen so I'm like well the
odds are against him right now the odds
are always all
we're gonna be against me on Monday but
they're against him too because it's
like he did the first couple days I
don't think I don't think it can happen
and of course they did the same thing
and he did the same thing
so it's just one of those things I say
the great the greatest of all time
players all you name them all they do
great things all the time that you not
they do things you're not supposed to do
pretty much all the time that's why
they're the greatest of all time he's
rockin and Tiger has proved that many
many many many times
he's Rocco Mediate it was ten years ago
this week finished runner-up to Tiger
Woods his best career finish and a major
on the PGA Tour you have sort of some
odd Fame attached to this rock owed deep
do you think you got more attention
because you didn't win as opposed to if
you had won that US Open over Tiger
Woods yeah you know I don't really know
nothing really amazing can't happen I
was accepted and notice that people
noticed I definitely definitely got that
more people knew who I was of course
because I was playing against Tiger if
there was anybody else in the event it
wouldn't have been in the event like
that the obviously because the number
one player in the world but you know I
guarantee you if I woulda won
well his leg was broken I mean of course
it's gonna be it was but but everyone
did say though oh yeah you know you
heard it and well he's got nothing to
lose and this isn't you know he has
nothing to lose well III did I had the
most coveted thing I want in my sport
which is the US Open trophy so I did
have everything to lose
we both did we both wanted it more than
you could imagine and only one of us got
to have it so yeah and that was the most
fun part of it was the attempt and this
and the going up against a guy that I
respect as much as anybody a golf and
the guy that I watched grow up basically
out there and they became the best guy
out there and it was fun trying to go up
and see what I could do with them and
the only way that's gonna happen is if
you're playing great golf on that type
of course then there's a shot most other
places you're going to get taken apart
but the open levels things out
especially if you're hitting it a little
crooked
did you understand how
injured he was at the time well what
Tiger did when we played a slushy money
I never noticed anything I didn't want
to thank anything you know I he never
showed me anything on Monday as far as
hurt not once
you never went down he never never
slowed down and he never did anything
and that's what you know the only way he
was not gonna play as if he couldn't
walk or couldn't could or as if you know
what I mean he was gonna play no matter
what obviously showed that the first
four days the first couple of days he
looked terrible as far as his but you
know the paint mm-hmm but I didn't see
anything Monday no any hit
he played pretty good money I mean
obviously did but I mean he he was
better Monday than he was the other days
as far as hitting his ball but it was
still you could tell he's still it
doesn't matter like eighteen to get up
on the last hole but I think his whole
evening the 19th hole we played and um
he eat drug but probably this tee shot
started I remember seeing it because
when you hear I'm like good boy that's
pretty far left and excited at least
thirty yards and that you know rolled
out to like 320 you know that that's
things that well I can't do that ever
it's not going to happen so you look at
that and go here is yeah cuz I I drove
it in left rough I had no chance to
reach at green unless I had a big mo
nasty kind of diving home got the right
that rolled 56 yards but I missed it
last I knew what was gonna happen with
me as far as way out but you know if he
misses that tee shot probably over you
know as far as you know if he can't
reach the green you know it's a battle
of the third shot it's probably over but
he didn't and he had to have it because
he had to have it and it was like yeah
5-iron in there I mean it was ridiculous
so yeah but you know just watching and
taking it all in and playing the best
golf I could play but you're right about
the getting beat a lot of opens like
that a lot of play not not to spend a
lot of playoffs but those can ruin
careers
okay that was 45 at the time so I was
you know I'm almost ready to go
champions going and five years but if I
would have like I tell people yeah if I
would have three putted 18 on Sunday or
thought I made a double bogey on 18 on
Sunday or something stuff would happen
or in the playoffs I I make
double on the last hole or in the lake
with my wedge or something my career is
in danger because I just gave away the
biggest event ever in front of the world
right in the middle of fairway and
that's happened to people and beats like
that hurt I mean it definitely hurt but
I I knew I was gonna recover because I
the test I had against me those four
five days especially that Monday I
passed
okay I just got beat by you know the
best guy whatever but my point is I I
took a lot out of that that well all the
stuff I worked on my whole life work
under the most intensive situations and
it would kind of work pretty much for
five days that told me I'm I'm okay but
it did hurt for a while took me a while
but when I wanted fries a couple years
later that that kind of lets set me free
a little bit because I didn't want the
open to be it because I knew I was only
five you know four or five six pointers
and regular doing them I've gone did you
save it was a goal but from that 2008 US
Open um that's when it comes up so that
pins all the open pins from that that
week every open has different pins right
so I got all the ones in my my player
badges on the side so I gave that's in
the museum so that they ask of course
you know I'm gonna say no and take home
whatever I gave it to them so you know
not not really the medal they give give
you for second as obvious I had that and
that's really yet you know I didn't get
like I said you know everybody makes fun
about the picture but I don't have a
picture of him and I that I wanted
personalized just so I could have it in
the show P you know because it's cool to
me it's cool but I really don't have
much than that memories that's huge and
and 99.9% of them are good ones and
reason and good reason for that
hey Rocco it's great to catch up with
you how you feeling yeah I'm feeling
great I'm a citizen sit on the citizens
I've missed it the loss everything's
everything's good I'm 55 and I'm hitting
it as good as I've ever hit it so having
a blast out on this tour PGA Tour
champion having a ball but it's as you
see these scores runs it's just like
playing the regular tour
five years ago if I had your versus
Tiger today for one round for the US
Open how do you think you'd do ten years
later I think it'd be the same type of
battle but unfortunately for me he's
really swinging right now and he's and
he's healthier yes and he doesn't have a
broken leg I mean I I think he's gonna
do crazy things I mean people look at me
crazy and I'm like this guy gone I mean
I looked at golf with the way he's
swinging that golf club right now and
I've paid attention for a lot of years
in a row watching him after after our
event and I'm it's good and you can see
what's going on I mean I think he's got
amazing things coming and III think he's
gonna not talk he's gonna shock the
world but not him hey Rocco great to
catch up with you thanks for joining us
and Rob dancing anytime you need me
thank you buddy that's Rocco Mediate
that was a great story for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on Direct TV or download the Dan Patrick
show at
[Music]